un mois et demi du congrès des
républicains qui désignera le candidat
du parti à l'élection présidentielle le
président de l air et dans notre région
dans la métropole lilloise hier à calais
aujourd'hui il passe ce matin à par le
studio de france bleu nord christian
jacob est l'invité du 6 9 ce matin
cécile vidéo bonjour christian jacob
bonjour va commencer par une actualité
du du matin on attendait le gouvernement
sur les carburants finalement il choisit
une mesure qui ne concerne pas
uniquement les automobilistes jean
castex a annoncé ce chèque inflation de
santoro en cette fin d'année pour les
français qui gagnent moins de 1000 euros
par mois est ce que c'est la bonne cible
selon vous je pense pas on est vraiment
sur
l'opération de com avec avec un chèque
cadeau je pense qu'il aurait mieux valu
s'attaquer aux causes d'abord sur
l'essence 70 pour cent des français
utilisent leur voiture pour aller
travailler on croise tous les jours les
artisans avec la leur camionnette sur
les routes où on a une explosion d une
explosion des coûts donc je pense que
c'est vraiment ça qu'il fallait qu'il
fallait cibler les automobilistes et les
autres sur les on les laisse alors qui a
également vu le gaz et d'électricité oui
enfin il ya le coût du carburant ça à
chaque français qui utilise sa voiture
s'en rend compte immédiatement sur sur
l'énergie là aussi il ya effectivement
et le choc on va y arriver dans l'est
dans les semaines qui viennent avec les
chauffages qui ce qui se met en route
c'est d'abord un choix
incohérent qui a été fait par le
gouvernement je pensais au nucléaire on
abandonne le nucléaire on l'arrête
maintenant le président est totalement
perdue donc nous annonce qu'on va
redémarrer le nucléaire sauf qu'il y à
il ya deux ans on annoncé la fermeture
de 14 de 14 réacteurs on a la chance
d'avoir une énergie
décarbonée à bas coûts utilisons le de
la même façon que sur les les
biocarburants on voit aujourd'hui qu'on
peut utiliser davantage les
biocarburants qui permettent de diminuer
les coûts pour les automobilistes c'est
ça qu'il fallait cibler un christian
jacob vous êtes dans les hauts de france
ces jours-ci c'est la région de xavier
bertrand l'un des six candidats à
l'investiture pour la présidentielle
est-ce que vous profitez de votre venue
pour le voir non mais je les ai vus il
ya deux jours et deux jours à paris et
écoutez moi je suis ravie de la manière
dont les choses se passent aux
républicains d'abord bon c'est depuis
deux ans les succès électoraux nous
avons gagné toutes les élections sans
exception depuis deux ans et puis tout
le monde est revenu dans la famille des
républicains
et on voit bien que l'ambiance a changé
chez nos militants parce que on est
vraiment en situation de pouvoir de
pouvoir gagner aux présidentielles à
condition d'être rassemblés mais pense
que tout le monde a pris conscience de
cela et les choses objectivement se
passe plutôt bien depuis maintenant
quelques années cette famille dont
xavier bertrand avait quitté en 2017 il
l'a été un peu contraint et forcé ainsi
ils voulaient l'investiture et l'air de
revenir et ce qu'il a pris sa carte
d'ailleurs est-ce que ça
s'est fait tout à fait est ravi qu'il
soit revenu envie qu'il soit revenu
comme comme valérie pécresse il fallait
que tout le monde revienne dans la
famille parce que l'enjeu ce sont les
les élections présidentielles où sa
mission
si on a réussi à gagner les les
municipales comme nous les avons gagnées
on l'oublié souvent mais les
républicains aujourd'hui c'est 56 % des
villes de plus de 9000 habitants en
france qui sont administrés par des
équipes les républicains rga des
exceptions notables iront de ville par
exemple attendu jeudi il n'empêche que
56% des villes de plus de 9000 ce sont
les républicains aux régionales
souvenez-vous la ya six ans le front
national était en tête au premier tour
dans six régions de france il ne l'a été
que dans une seule cette fois ci avec
une formidable victoire aux régionales
et aux départementales et toussant
l'obtenu comment en étant rassemblée et
unie rassemblée unie la droite gagne
christian jacob le président des verts
et notre invité ce matin sur france bleu
nord il répond à vos questions cécile
bidault alors avant le congrès du 4
décembre il y aura quatre débats
télévisés entre vos six candidats quatre
débats c'est beaucoup est ce que vous
craignez pas qu'à la longue on finisse
par voir des dissensions voir des
divisions non on voit aussi ce qui va
rassembler c'est le sait le défi je
pense qu'il est il est important moi je
tenais à ce que le choix du candidat
soit fait par nos militants pour moi
c'est essentiel
c'est eux qui sont l'âme de notes de
notre famille politique c'est à vous de
faire le choix mais il faut aussi que la
droite façon tant de ses propositions
à l'ensemble des français et quoi de
mieux que les débats et d'être présent
dans toute la sphère médiatique et donc
on va avoir effectivement à partir de de
la semaine prochaine fin de celle
d'après dix ans dans dans 15 jours
jusqu'à la fin de l'année ben je pense
une belle occupation de l'espace
médiatique quand la droite elles sont un
moment ou un autre vous même vous
prendrai position non dans le rôle qui
est le mien aujourd'hui c'est de
rassembler c'est un métier en soi de
doha c'est
de rassembler tout le monde écoute et on
a on a formidablement bien réussi et moi
mon travail c'est de faire en sorte que
et bien l'ensemble de la jirs est de 2,2
de l'équipe de l'équipe militante soit
effectivement au travail de 5 ou matin
parce que le 5 au matin c'est autre
chose qui s'engage on est en train ce
moment là vraiment sur la dernière ligne
droite de la présidentielle c'est pour
ça qu'il faut absolument réussir ces
débats réussir
cette ce rassemblement entre nos
candidats le 5 décembre au matin il y
aura un candidat les républicains pour
représenter la droite et le centre à
l'élection présidentielle jacob vous
vous rendez à quelle est aujourd'hui où
la question migratoire est très
importante si un président ait l'air
était élu
à la prochaine présidentielle comment
gérez vous cette situation qui semble
insoluble il y a d'abord ça a été
annoncé par emmanuel macron il n'a rien
fait la renégociation des accords du
touquet il ya calais n'a pas vocation à
être la zone de douane de douvres et
aujourd'hui soit on trouve un accord
avec les britanniques mais pour ça il
faut effectivement être dans une
opération de bras de fer ont leur on le
voit bien soit on trouve cet accord soit
sinon effectivement on met que la zone
de douane soit en angleterre elle n'en a
pas vocation est la voir à calais
aujourd'hui ensuite au delà du sujet des
migrants c'est l'ensemble des politiques
d'immigration qui est totalement hors de
contrôle avec ce gouvernement on a une
explosion des demandes d'asile on exclut
une explosion l'arrivée des démineurs
isolé on n'a jamais eu un aussi faible
système de mise en place de de
raccompagnement aux frontières 90% des
obligations de quitter le territoire ne
sont pas effectifs 90% jamais je crois
le la politique migratoire était à
l'abandon comme le lait avec ce
gouvernement il faut en parlerait
aujourd'hui notamment avec la maire de
calais natacha bouchart merci christian
j'accorde avoir été l'invité de france
bleu nord ce matin bonne journée merci à
vous l'entretien devrait écouter sur
l'application france bluffant